wenn ich entscheiden müsste freiheit für
die juden oder holocaust dann wäre es
der holocaust
sie sollten ohne gnade ausgelöscht und
israel in eine große faschistische
gemeinschaft sauna verwandelt werden
menschenverachtenden dialoge wie dieser
normaler umgangston auf ihren marsch org
einem der größten nazi treffpunkte im
netz hier tauschten sich auch deutsche
rechtsextremisten aus doch jetzt wurde
er in march gelegt tausende seiten hass
antisemitismus und ns verherrlichung
alles öffentlich ein rechercheteam von
zdf heute wollte wissen welche deutschen
neonazis waren dort aktiv das team
durchsuchte das liegt nach nutzernamen e
mail und ip adressen
es stieß auf einen deutschen nutzer der
sich in viele diskussion einbrachte
volksverhetzung es nicht so ein problem
wie ihr denkt nur idioten werden deshalb
geschnappt kontaktiert mich wenn ihr in
deutschland aktiv sein wollt erkundigte
sich auch nach videos der atomwaffen
division
das ist eine rechtsextremistische
terrorgruppe ihre anhänger sind in den
usa für fünf morde verantwortlich
auch in deutschland hat sich ein ableger
der atomwaffen division gegründet
die politiker erhielten morddrohungen
von ihnen doch wer ist der deutsche user
das rechercheteam findet seinen
nutzernamen auch auf anderen radikalen
webseiten auf fisch ist fort schreibt er
auch in der npd jugend und in einer
rechten kameradschaft gewesen zu sein
auch auf explosives nett war der nutzer
aktiv inzwischen nahmen die behörden
dass sprengstoff forum vom netz dort gab
er anderen tipps wie man sprengstoff
herstellt und an waffen und munition
kommt die hinweise führen zu einem
bekannten neonazi aus eisen nacht zwei
fotos auf einem privaten instagram
account gepostet zeigen ihn mit
mitgliedern seiner kampfsport gruppe auf
dem weg nach tschechien zu einem
schießtraining katharina könig preuß
beobachtet die neonazis in eisenach seit
jahren die linken-politikerin traut der
szene sogar anschläge zu auch weil die
polizei nicht gut genug aufgestellt sei
da braucht es aus meiner sicht viel mehr
personal aber auch entsprechende
sachmittel auf seiten der polizei und
zum zweiten es ist ein wahnsinnig
verzweigtes weites netzwerk das ist auch
nicht nur ein netzwerks und das sind
dutzende wenn ich sogar hunderte die
atomwaffen division ist nur eine davon
als zdf heute den jungen eisen nachher
mit der recherche konfrontiert will er
sich nicht äußern
auf instagram schreibt er danach nie
habe er für die atomwaffen division
deutschland gearbeitet
ob die gruppe in thüringen aktiv ist
prüft derzeit der verfassungsschutz in
march ist offline das weltweite netz des
hasses aber lebt weiter